a la tarde y el informativo estrella de
la televisión turca hard tv está a punto
de empezar irfan de armenia y uno de los
presentadores de televisión más
reconocidos del país se prepara para el
programa él y sus compañeros realizan
uno de los informativos más vistos y más
combativos de turquía y por ello pagan
las consecuencias
facing cada día somos amenazados dos
colegas de la cadena recibieron una
paliza en la puerta de la televisión y
castigos solo por lo que habían dicho
por sus palabras artísticos de edwards
hace 4 años turquía el país del mundo
que más reportero se encarcelaba la
situación ha cambiado pero la presión
sigue pero dónde eroglu representante de
reporteros sin fronteras en turquía lo
sufre en carne propia está siendo
juzgado por supuesta propaganda
terrorista y podría ser condenado a 14
años de cárcel
tenemos un presidente que dirige
personalmente los procesos penales en
este país y que cambia el orden de todo
el sistema judicial por desgracia
la represión no obliga a muchos a buscar
alternativas y ese es el caso de tim
cook que fue despedida de una gran
televisión por criticar al presidente
turco ahora trabaja a través de youtube
donde concentra millones de seguidores
acosan primero en twitter y después
pasan a los medios convencionales y
televisiones leales al gobierno que
empiezan a señalar te a decir cosas
terribles sobre ti y sobre todo si eres
mujer siempre ponen una connotación
sexual para atacarnos con las elecciones
presidenciales programadas para dentro
de un año la presión contra los
periodistas aumenta
[Música]
y en beige maíz ante la baja popularidad
de erdogán estos comicios se prevén
históricos ser fan se prepara
este es el momento más importante de
nuestras vidas no tenemos mucho más
tiempo veremos quedan seis meses o años
para las elecciones y veremos qué pasa
podemos continuar haciendo las noticias
podremos continuar viviendo en turquía
que ver si este presentador como muchos
teme al futuro a pesar de la presión el
periodismo independiente se esfuerza por
sobrevivir en turquía
[Música]